moving from the ego to the spirit do we
have an example of a television show or
film right now yeah so I have a movie
that I actually mentioned in my book
storyline finding gold in your life
story and it's the movie up in the air
so George Clooney's character at the
beginning of the story his he's all ego
and it is the recognition make what we
see in the beginning of the movie is his
highfalutin single life style that is a
result of him being able to fire people
through going to them and then the
inciting incident
is when he is told yeah you are going to
be grounded and you are going to now
fire people on the computer so the
dilemma that puts him in is he's going
to lose his highfalutin single lifestyle
that is led by the belief that we see in
his motivational speeches of go through
life with an empty backpack and non
commitment and detachment so this is a
negative narrative that is leading him
and at the midpoint when Natalie I
believe is the character saying if I
remember correctly she's the one who got
them grounded so when he's along Natalie
side and and he falls into the water
with his biggest fear which is the
picture of his sister in her fiance so
commitment so we have the symbolism of
commitment he falls into the water and
she says to him you put yourself in a
cocoon of self banishment so this is
when the character is starting to
recognize that his philosophy is no
longer serving him and then we see him
take an action and go to the house of
his love interest Alex which he wouldn't
normally
have done and he discovers that she's
married with kids and and then we see
him take another option which is to tell
his sister that he will walk her down
the aisle and she said oh we don't need
you we already have someone so this is
the point where the character is
recognizing that the ego is no longer
serving and there is a recognition that
now it's not just about achieving the
goal of not getting grounded because of
his own personal needs there is a
recognition because the woman jumps off
the bridge in one of the situations that
if people are fired on the computer they
won't have the personal rapport of
having someone in person to create trust
and security and therefore more
situations like that could happen so he
awakens to the idea that the achievement
of the goal isn't just about him and his
personal needs of wanting to keep a high
falutin single lifestyle it is about the
greater good
you